right if you're not in the middle of the
pitch I'm going to kill you you want to
be the first victim thank you very much
hello and welcome to Playstation grenade
I survived my first ever livestream last
week and invited you guys to play
fortnight with me we had John wick
faceoffs in the hotel and even had a
full-on war between original John wicks
the ones we call the Reapers and these
new John wicks fYI the Reapers dominated
to finish the stream we played a game of
John wicks A's with fifty of the grenade
community and here's what happened John
wick says default dance
[Music]
[Applause]
[Music]
[Applause]
okay I'm gonna stand on this center
point can you make a circle around me so
it's easier to turn to see you all
alright our ability to make circles is
not fantastic guys I'll apply John wicks
haze Crouch I want to apologize John
wick says John wick says jump
default dance
sorry you know the rules of it if it
didn't said John dipping wick see it's
over for you John wick stays spin round
on the spot non-stop John wick says
stand on a roof nice come back down John
wick says come back down make a circle
this is the greatest game ever
I won't lie I'm really enjoying this
John wicks a spray the floor
the aerosols John wick sees pickaxe to
the person next to you John weeks a
stand on a roof I'll be shooting the
last person off I've mastered the
ability of standing so incredibly still
that I become invisible to the eye
nope
what are we doing we've got 33 more
people it's going well it's going well
John wick sees Crouch I can't hear you
what John wick sees jump
hey I don't bring I know you're trying
to just enjoy your day off I don't mean
to bother you but I just got a quick
autograph please
I had no idea that grenade went off then
so I'm sorry about that the person who
threw it was butter bear seven-11
you half-breed named James sir that's
the video
John week says get on top of the
resurrection man
10 9 8 7
good timing
good 21 little of the yeah dummy come on
get on
dude I'm catching you up [ __ ] you
follow up on lucky
perfect timing Rex you're a legend right
John wick says get on top of the
cathedral roof the church group done
with days
boys not looking good for fellow John
wick what's he gonna do John wicks haze
get in the building behind John wick to
your West
the last person will be shot John wick
says dodge the grenades
I am scum I apologize come on come on
come on it's close who is it gonna be
it's you come on come on take it take it
like birthday the woman your mark
John wick says crouch John wick says
jump spray look this is a real man he
knows he's done wrong
it's very sorry that you are a legend
John wick says get to the center of the
circle John wick sees dance
John Luke says get away from the grenade
it was at this moment he knew John wick
says go to the edge of the island Tom
weekdays do not get thrown off the cliff
aah
ticking John weeks a spin around
this is where you can see people's
sensitivity look at that one
dancing under John Wick's ace
crouch-jump don't make it with you
wasn't it was it John wick was it John
wick don't work was it you John wick was
it you is jumping yes or no tell me yes
or no was it you who was jumping be
Booker would you say yes
was it don't do it was it John wick
everyone yes or no
John wick day spray can we say sins like
that John wicks a dance
[Music]
don't wake say's deep almonds
[Music]
yes yes yes yes yet brilliant you're all
doing at seven left what else could we
do John wick says jump Crouch John wick
says jump John wicks is no coach
jump oh you are legends you are legends
John wick sees not John wick says get to
the center of the next circle John wicks
a pickaxe battle
John makes a stop don't fixate stay in
the center of the circle Johnny say
don't die why you bullet me unlucky you
three onlooking three left follow with
the pot John wick says Joe Crouch John
wick says Crouch John wick series and
use this launchpad
John wicks a default dance
oh look he's Nighthawks JonBenet's
throat don't wait size jump John wick
last thing John wick says his fight to
win
oh we have a winner we have a winner
indeed the winner was destruction XL who
I actually know from when I first
started playing fortnight I haven't
spoken to him since last year and
suddenly he appears in this game
destruction XL also played Shawn in our
terrible attempt at making a fortnight
comedy sketch I'll link it is that bad
I'll link it now it was terrible thank
you very much for watching and thank you
even more if you took part in the
livestream I really do appreciate it but
the biggest question of all is should we
do it again shall we have another
community event I hope you say yes
because I absolutely loved it
I'm Adam from PlayStation granade please
come talk to me over on Twitter
I'm Adam grenade over there anyway I'll
get out of your face I'll be seeing you
mr. wick
[Music]